This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The United States Marine Corps buys a lot of earplugs. Visit any military base and you'll find them. Under the bleachers at the firing range, in the bottoms of washing machines, they are cheap and effective at making noise, less noisy. Most earplugs reduce noise by about 30 decibels. That is Mary Roach, author of a bunch of great books,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。美国海军陆战队购买了大量的耳塞。参观任何一个军事基地，你都能找到它们。在靶场看台下面、洗衣机底部，它们便宜且能有效降低噪音，让声音变小。大多数耳塞能将噪音降低约 30 分贝。那是玛丽·罗奇，她写过许多优秀的图书，
her latest one is called Grunt. It's about the science of humans at war. 30 decibels can be significant. Every three decibel increase in a loud noise cuts in half. The amount of time you can be exposed without risking hearing damage. To put that another way, an unprotected human ear can spend eight hours a day exposed to
她的最新力作名为《Grunt》（硬汉兵器）。这本书讲述了人类战争中的科学。30 分贝的降噪效果非常显著。在面对巨大噪音时，分贝每增加 3 分贝，你在不承担听力受损风险的前提下所能暴露的时长就会减半换句话说，不受保护的人类耳朵每天可以暴露在
85 decibels without incurring hearing loss. That's the level of freeway noise. 85 decibels is also the level of a crowded restaurant. But if you go up to 115 decibels, things like a chainsaw, or a really loud concert. Your safe exposure time is only half a minute before your hearing can be affected. So without ear plugs, you should only be exposed to the sound of a chainsaw for about 30 seconds. But with ear plugs, you've got closer to 8 hours. In a military situation, a reduction of 30 decibels is especially helpful with a steady, grinding background in, like, say, a Bradley tank clattering over asphalt, or the thrum of a black-hawk helicopter.
85 分贝的环境中八小时而不会导致听力丧失。这大约是高速公路噪音的水平。85 分贝也是熙熙攘攘的餐厅里的噪音水平。但如果你去到 115 分贝的环境，比如电锯声或非常吵闹的音乐会。在你听力受损之前，安全暴露时间只有半分钟。因此，如果不戴耳塞，你接触电锯声音的时间不应超过 30 秒左右。但有了耳塞，你的安全时间就能接近 8 小时。在军事行动中，30 分贝的降噪效果在面对持续刺耳的背景噪音时特别有用，比如布雷德利战车碾过沥青路面的轰鸣，或是黑鹰直升机的轰鸣声。
But there's a problem with earplugs as the solution on a battlefield. I will tell you that I've never seen a Marine wear earplugs in a combat operation. That's Erin O'Wan-Soo. It's been eight years as an infantry Marine and served a tour of duty in Fallujah Iraq. And this is Eric Fallon. In over 24 years of military experience, I've never seen soldiers put a passive ear plug in and go on a dismounted patrol.
但将耳塞作为战场解决方案存在一个问题。我可以告诉你，我从未见过任何一名海军陆战队员在作战行动中佩戴耳塞。那是艾伦·奥万-苏。他曾担任了八年步兵海军陆战队员，并在伊拉克费卢杰服役过一个轮次。这是埃里克·法伦。在超过 24 年的从军经历中，我从未见过士兵们塞入被动式耳塞然后去执行徒步巡逻任务。
Soldiers aren't using their ear plugs because when they do, they can't hear what's happening around them. And with unprotected ears, a lot of service members are coming home from battle with tenitis, which is ringing in your ears or hearing loss. It's not uncommon. Anyone, especially in the infantry, will pretty much tell you that they have hearing loss.
士兵们不使用耳塞，因为戴上后他们就听不到周围发生的事情了。由于耳朵缺乏保护，许多军人在退役回家时都患上了耳鸣（即耳朵里嗡嗡作响）或听力损失。这并不少见。任何人，尤其是步兵，几乎都会告诉你他们有听力损失。
When Aaron and his buddies get together in social situations, everyone speaks a little louder. You know, when we get together, everybody knows who has the worst amount of hearing loss. Typically, if it's a good set of friends, we know which year they tend to have hearing loss in. I can tell you two or three friends right off top of my head. I know, OK, yeah, he got hit by an IED on his right side.
当艾伦和他的战友们在社交场合聚在一起时，每个人说话的声音都会大一点。你知道的，当我们聚在一起时，大家都知道谁的听力损失最严重。通常，如果是一群很好的朋友，我们甚至知道他们倾向于在哪边耳朵上有听力损失。我脑海里马上就能说出两三个朋友。我知道，好吧，是的，他右侧挨过简易爆炸装置（IED）的袭击。
I need to speak to his left ear. But while Aaron's fellow Marines are naturally understanding about his hearing loss, his wife and kids find it challenging. They actually end up getting frustrated with me, and it's, I don't know, you just try to play it off sometimes, pretend like you heard what they had to say, and try to pick it up later on in the conversation, or figure it out later, or ask them as though you forgot.
我需要对着他的左耳说话。然而，虽然艾伦的战友们对他的听力损失自然很理解，但他的妻子和孩子却觉得这很不方便。他们最后其实会对我感到沮丧，而且，怎么说呢，有时候你只能顺着假装过去，假装你听清了他们的话，然后试图在接下来的对话中琢磨出来，或者事后弄清楚，或者像你忘了似地再去问他们。
You didn't actually forget, you just never heard them. When you really think about the advent of black gunpowder, which is really when the military became an extremely noisy environment, think about how long we've lived with that. Really without a solution, the solution is to put something in your ears that blocks the sound. And oh, by the way, it doesn't just block the sound
你其实不是忘了，你只是根本没听见。如果你仔细想想黑火药的出现，那正是军队变成一个极度嘈杂环境的时期，想想我们与这种环境共存了多久。真的可以说是没有解决方案，唯一的解决方案就是塞住耳朵来阻挡声音。而且，顺便说一句，它阻挡的不仅仅是
that we want to prevent, It blocks all the sound. Since World War II, the VA has been reporting on what kinds of injuries they treat. And tonight's Inherien loss have always been the number one and number two most prevalent injuries to service members. Eric Fallon has been studying how to protect the hearing of service members for a long time. He's an audiologist. An audiologist is a medical professional that is concerned with the auditory system. Eric used to be the chief audiologist at Walter Reed Medical Center. Some audiologists work with patients to give
我们想要防范的声音，它阻挡了所有的声音。自二战以来，退伍军人事务部（VA）一直在报告他们治疗的伤病种类。而听力损失一直高居军人常见伤病的前两名。埃里克·法伦长期以来一直在研究如何保护军人的听力。他是一名听力学家。听力学家是关注听觉系统的医疗专业人员。埃里克曾任沃尔特·里德医疗中心的首席听力学家。一些听力学家与患者合作，为
them hearing tests and diagnose what kind of hearing disorder they have, but Eric's main focus is trying to find solutions. The right protective solutions that not only protect their hearing, but enhance their performance in some way. Eric now works for the company 3M, designing hearing protection for military use, and he's fond of saying that the military has a noise problem, but... We have a significant quiet problem. What he means is that service members in combat need ear protection that works for them in both environments, because the transition from quiet to noisy can happen very, very quickly.
他们进行听力测试并诊断他们患有哪种听力障碍，但埃里克的重点是寻找解决方案。寻找那些不仅能保护听力，还能在某种程度上提升他们表现的正确防护方案。埃里克现在为 3M 公司工作，为军事用途设计听力防护装备，他常说军队存在噪音问题，但……我们存在严重的安静问题。他的意思是，作战人员需要能在两种环境中都适用的听力保护装置，因为从安静到嘈杂的转变可能会发生得非常非常快。
In a war zone, you have to consider everything. Even just walking down the road has a strategy to it. The quote unquote, killing radius of a fragmentation grenade is 15 feet. If troops walked along in a clump like tourists, a single grenade could kill a bunch of them at once. So they try to keep at least 15 feet between each other on patrols. But the more spread out they are, the harder it is to hear one another. Troops in combat might walk in the quiet for hours.
身处战区，你必须考虑到方方面面。甚至仅仅是走在路上也包含着战术。碎片手榴弹所谓的“杀伤半径”是 15 英尺。如果部队像游客一样挤成一团走在一起，一枚手榴弹就能同时炸死他们中的很多人。因此他们在巡逻时尽量彼此保持至少 15 英尺的距离。但他们分散得越开，彼此听见对方说话就越困难。作战部队可能会在安静中行军数小时。
The only noise being just a little bit of chatting, the sound of gravel crunching under their boots. And then suddenly, this is a video that Eric Fallon likes to show of troops on patrol in Iraq. These troops were just walking along. Hey, buddy! And then all of a sudden,
唯一的噪音只是一点点聊天声，以及靴子踩碎砾石的声音。然后突然间，这是一段埃里克·法伦喜欢播放的视频，展示了部队在伊拉克巡逻的情景。这些部队当时正走着。嘿，伙计！然后突然间，
things got kinetic very quickly. Hey, buddy! Are you okay? And then all of a sudden, things got kinetic very quickly. In the video when the troop comes under fire, all the soldiers fall to the ground and begin shooting. It's loud, and they probably aren't wearing hearing protection. But Eric says the potential damage to their ears isn't the only problem. Their lives are in danger, and their hearing is one of the main things helping them figure out what to do.
局势变得非常紧张。嘿，伙计！你还好吗？然后突然间，局势变得非常紧张。视频中，当部队遭到火力打击时，所有士兵都趴到地上开始开枪。声音很大，他们可能没有佩戴听力保护装置。但埃里克表示，对耳朵的潜在损害并不是唯一的问题。他们的生命正处于危险之中，而他们的听力是帮助他们弄清楚该做什么的主要工具之一。
Just because they're being shot at doesn't mean that they understand what's happening to them. They may not know, am I being shot at by 50 people or three people? What's happening to the left of me? What's happening to the right of me? One of the major tools to figure out what's happening in this situation is radio. With a radio, you can connect to someone who has more of a bird's-eye view of the place. This might be another soldier somewhere on a roof, or someone monitoring from a drone camera. Communication will help the person on the ground answer all the questions running through
遭到射击并不意味着他们明白自己正在经历什么。他们可能不知道，向我开枪的是 50 个人还是 3 个人？我左边发生了什么？我右边发生了什么？弄清这种情况下正在发生什么的主要工具之一是无线电设备。有了电台，你就可以与那些对该地点有更宏观上帝视角的人取得联系。这可能是屋顶上的另一个士兵，或者是通过无人机摄像头进行监控的人员。通讯将帮助地面人员回答那一刻
their head in that moment. What do I do? Do I push through the assault? Do I hold in place? Do I wait for the quick reaction force to come and help us? Do I call in air support? But it's loud. They can probably barely hear what the other people around them are saying, let alone what's on the radio. And if I can't hear the signal, I may be missing the information that I need to make the right decision. And so if you see in that video, there's a young soldier laying on the ground communicating
脑海中涌现的所有问题。我该怎么办？我要发起冲锋吗？我要坚守阵地吗？我要等待快速反应部队来支援我们吗？我要呼叫空中支援吗？但声音太大了。他们可能连周围其他人说话的声音都快听不见了，更不用说电台里的声音了。如果我听不清信号，我可能会错过做出正确决定所需的信息。所以在那个视频里，你会看到一个年轻士兵趴在地上通过
over the radio and just before the video stops, you'll hear him say, I can't hear you. A point that I try to make whenever I use that video is that's probably one of the more important communications that not only that person but his team members will ever have in their lives because they're under direct enemy fire. Being able to hear the radio and each other is crucial to their survival. Eric believes that he has a solution to this problem. He thinks that service members on dismounted combat patrols like the one in that video
电台进行通讯，就在视频结束前不久，你会听到他说：“我听不清你说话。”每当我使用这段视频时，我试图强调的一点是，这可能是那个人以及他的队员一生中所进行的最重要的通讯之一，因为他们正遭受敌人的直接火力打击。能够听到电台的声音以及彼此的声音对他们的生存至关重要。埃里克相信他找到了解决这个问题的办法。他认为像视频中那样进行徒步作战巡逻的军人
should be wearing a device called T-CAPS. So tactical communication and protective systems or T-CAPS are products that are designed to not only deliver hearing protection, but to allow you a better ability to hear what's happening around you so you can maintain some situational awareness. T-Caps come in a couple of styles. One style fits inside your ear, kind of like a pair of ear buds,
应该佩戴一种名为 T-CAPS 的设备。因此，战术通讯与防护系统（简称 T-CAPS）这类产品旨在不仅提供听力保护，还能让你更好地听到周围发生的事情，从而维持一定的态势感知能力。T-Caps 有几种款式。一种款式适合塞入耳内，有点像一对耳机，
and the other style fits over your ear, and they look like the earmuffs you might wear while operating power tools. Both styles are equipped with environmental microphones that pick up the sounds around you and feed them into your ears at levels that your eardrums can tolerate. In some cases these products integrate into a radio system so that you can have more seamless to a radio communications. With the radio feature you could be talking with a drone operator or communicating with the command center, and you can actually hear what they're saying to you because the device is blocking out other noise. And yes, 3M, the company Eric works for Cells, T-Caps,
另一种款式则是罩在耳朵外面，看起来就像你在使用电动工具时戴的耳罩。这两种款式都配备了环境麦克风，可以捕捉你周围的声音，并以你的耳膜能够承受的音量将其输送进你的耳朵。在某些情况下，这些产品可以集成到无线电系统中，以便你可以进行更顺畅的电台通讯。借助电台功能，你可以与无人机操作员交谈或与指挥中心通讯，并且你真的能听清他们对你说的话，因为该设备正在屏蔽其他噪音。是的，埃里克工作的 3M 公司销售 T-Caps，
but he's also an audiologist who's dedicated his career to protecting the hearing of people in the military. Eric sent us a few of the over-the-ear style T-Caps headsets to try out. Each pair have a power button that allows you to toggle between a few settings. 99PI producers Katie Mingle and Sam Greenspanan tested out the tea caps in front of our office where there's been a bunch of loud construction happening all week, and Katie recorded what the world sounds like through her tea caps. So in this clip, Katie and Sam are standing on the sidewalk wearing tea caps, looking like a couple of weirdos basically.
但他同时也是一名听力学家，将自己的职业生涯奉献给了保护军人听力的事业。埃里克给我们寄来了一些外耳罩式的 T-Caps 耳机供我们试用。每对耳机都有一个电源按钮，允许你在几种设置之间切换。99PI 的制作人凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）和萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）在我们的办公室外测试了这款 T-caps，我们办公室外面一整周都有大量的嘈杂建筑施工，凯蒂录下了通过 T-caps 听到的世界是什么样的。在这段音频中，凯蒂和萨姆正戴着 T-caps 站在人行道上，基本上看起来像两个怪人。
People are walking past, a construction worker is sweeping, and despite the fact that they're wearing big, padded earmuffs, they can hear it all really well. Because the environmental microphones are picking up the noise around them and feeding it into their ears. That's Sam talking to Katie using the radio feature on the T-Caps. Now someone has started to saw through the concrete nearby, but the T-caps are attenuating the sound, so that Sam and Katie can still hear it, but it's a much lower volume. But if they take the T-caps off... I won't make it listen that very long, but basically, the T-caps allowed Katie and Sam
人们从旁走过，一名建筑工人正在扫地，尽管他们戴着厚厚的大耳罩，但他们把这一切都听得真真切切。因为环境麦克风正在捕捉周围的噪音并将其传入他们的耳中。那是萨姆在使用 T-Caps 的电台功能与凯蒂对话。现在有人开始在附近用电锯切割混凝土，但 T-caps 正在减弱声音，所以萨姆和凯蒂依然能听到声音，但音量小得多了。但如果他们摘下 T-caps……我不会让大家听太久，但基本上，T-caps 让凯蒂和萨姆
to communicate through some very loud construction noises while also protecting their ears. And when it was quiet, they were able to hear the environment around them, soft sounds, like sweeping and people talking. T-caps are also being marketed for use in industrial and construction settings, just like the one Katie and Sam were standing in the middle of.
能够在非常嘈杂的施工噪音中进行交流，同时保护了他们的耳朵。而当周围安静时，他们能够听到周围的环境，比如扫地的声音和人们说话的轻柔声音。T-caps 也被市场推广用于工业和建筑环境，就像凯蒂和萨姆刚才站在正中间的那种环境。
In the military, they've been used since the early 2000s, mostly by special operations groups like Navy SEALs. But they're not standard issue, even for troops in combat who would be exposed to the kind of noise that can damage your hearing. The conventional forces do what I think that conventional forces have done for many, many years. They just accept that communicating is going to be a challenge. Communication challenges and hearing loss
在军队中，它们自 20 世纪 2000 年代初以来就被投入使用，主要由海军海豹突击队等特种作战小组使用。但它们并非标准配备，即使对于那些会暴露在可能损害听力的噪音中的作战部队也是如此。常规部队所做的事，我认为也是常规部队多年来一直在做的事。他们只是接受了交流将是一个挑战这一现实。通讯挑战和听力损失
were so much a part of the culture of combat that Eric says when he was a soldier he actually wanted hearing loss so that people would know he had experienced. So if you didn't have a degree of hearing loss it was obvious that you were one of the new guys and that you had not really been around much noise and you really had not fired that many artillery rounds down range. While soldiers are actively serving, they do have to undergo fairly comprehensive hearing tests and periodic check-ups. These tests are administered by an audiologist, but the results of those tests get passed on to the unit commander and he or she decides what to do with them.
在战斗文化中占有如此大的比重，以至于埃里克说，当他还是个士兵时，他实际上希望自己有听力损失，这样别人就会知道他经历过这一切。所以，如果你没有一定程度的听力损失，那就很明显你是新兵之一，你并没有真正经历过太多噪音，也没有在靶场打过那么多炮弹。在士兵积极服役期间，他们确实必须接受相当全面的听力测试和定期检查。这些测试由听力学家管理，但测试结果会传递给部队指挥官，由他或她决定如何处理。
And a soldier who is found to have degraded hearing often won't be taken out of their position. We're just so accustomed to finding workarounds with hearing loss. You will sometimes find soldiers that have a significant degree of hearing loss. But their unit leadership may be so dependent on that person that they also want that person to remain where they are. I look forward to the day when we put as much emphasis on maintaining good hearing as we do good vision. Eric has found that in order to get the military interested in protecting people's hearing,
被发现听力受损的士兵通常不会被调离岗位。我们对寻找听力损失的变通办法已经习以为常了。你有时会发现有些士兵有相当严重的听力损失。但他们的部队领导层可能太依赖这个人了，以至于他们也希望这个人留在原来的岗位上。我期待着这样一天的到来：我们对保持良好听力的重视程度能达到像对待良好视力那样。埃里克发现，为了让军队对保护人们的听力产生兴趣，
he's had to sell it differently. But that didn't really work. It's not a unit commander's job to be concerned with the VA's spends on hearing loss. When Eric talked to unit commanders, he had to make the argument tactical. He had to explain that when people can hear they can be more effective on the battlefield. This points to a larger disconnect between the Department of Defense, which is tasked
他必须换一种方式来推销。但这并没有真正起作用。关注退伍军人事务部在听力损失上花了多少钱并不是部队指挥官的工作。当埃里克与部队指挥官交谈时，他必须从战术角度进行论证。他必须解释说，当人们能够听清声音时，他们在战场上就能发挥更大的效能。这指向了国防部（负责
with defending the nation and the VA, which provides health care to veterans. If the DOD is given a choice between spending their money on bombs or hearing protection, it's not hard to see why they might choose to kick the can to the VA. But to defend the Department of Defense, they have made an effort in the last couple of decades to do better. There's more testing than there used to be, and in 2009 they established the Hearing Center of Excellence, which researches hearing loss and advocates for more protection.
保卫国家）与退伍军人事务部（为退伍军人提供医疗保健）之间更大的脱节。如果国防部面临选择，是将资金花在炸弹上还是听力保护上，我们不难理解为什么他们可能会选择把这个皮球踢给退伍军人事务部。但平心而论，在过去几十年里，国防部确实做出了努力，做得更好了。现在的测试比以前更多了，并在 2009 年成立了听力卓越中心，该中心专门研究听力损失并倡导更多的保护措施。
This invisible injury of hearing loss is very significant. The big part of our job is to advocate and build awareness. That's Colonel Mark Packer. He's the director of the Hearing Center of Excellence. And he says, yeah, T-Caps are great, but they're not perfect. All hearing protection has some fallibility.
这种隐形的听力损失非常严重。我们工作很大一部分是进行倡导并建立意识。那是马克·帕克（Mark Packer）上校。他是听力卓越中心的 निदेशक（主任）。他说，是的，T-Caps 很棒，但它们并非完美无缺。所有的听力保护设备都有一定的缺陷。
If you're out on a hot mission in the desert and you have those earmuffs down over your ears, they are hot. Soldiers might remove them and then be unprotected when they need it. Other arguments against T-Caps, they are this extra thing to carry and they have to be charged and if they break they're expensive to replace. Not everybody
如果你在沙漠中执行炎热的任务，把那些耳罩戴在耳朵上，它们会很热。士兵们可能会把它们摘下来，因而在需要时得不到保护。反对 T-caps 的其他理由还有：它们是需要额外携带的东西，必须充电，而且如果损坏了更换成本很高。并不是每个人
needs a $1,500 tactical radio device. There are some solutions in between T-caps and the cheapest foam ear plugs. There's what's called level dependent ear plugs that are made to protect against high impulse noises like weapons fire, while allowing other environmental noises to pass through. But Eric and others we spoke to said that these ear plugs still make it difficult to hear the environment around you, and for that reason a lot of people will opt not to wear them. Whether T-caps are the solution for all combat troops or not, it's worth saying that Colonel Packer and Eric Fallon, they're basically on the same side about this, and they're both
都需要一个价值 1500 美元的战术电台设备。在 T-caps 和最便宜的泡沫耳塞之间还有一些折中方案。有一种叫做与电平相关的耳塞，旨在防范武器射击等高脉冲噪音，同时允许其他环境噪音穿透进来。但埃里克和我们交谈过其他人表示，这些耳塞仍然让人很难听清周围的环境，出于这个原因，很多人会选择不戴它们。无论 T-caps 是否是所有作战部队的解决方案，值得一提的是，帕克上校和埃里克·法伦在这件事上基本上站在同一边，他们都在
working sometimes together to find a solution to one of the oldest, most prevalent, and most invisible problems in the military. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Mary Roach and produced by Katie Mingle, with Delaney Hall, Shreefusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kurt Colesstead, Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. This episode was based off a chapter of Mary Roach's excellent, best-selling book, Grunt, the Curious Science of Humans at War. I cannot recommend her books enough.
有时共同努力，试图解决军队中历史最久远、最普遍、最隐形的问题之一。本周的 99% Invisible 由玛丽·罗奇报道，由凯蒂·明格制作，参与制作的还有德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、施里·优素福（Shree Yusuf）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colesstead）、萨姆·格林斯潘、埃弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马斯。本杰目改编自玛丽·罗奇那本优秀的畅销书《Grunt: The Curious Science of Humans at War》中的一个章节。我极力推荐她的书。
They are the best time you can have learning weird things about science. We are a project of 91.7K ALW, St. Francisco, Radio Row, Inbeatable, Downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, follow all the people who make this show on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to click around the hundreds and hundreds of stories on 99pi.org. RADIO TAPI-O-R-X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它们是你了解关于科学的古怪事物时能度过的最好时光。我们是来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心无线电排（Radio Row）Unbeatable、旧金山 91.7KALW 的一个项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并给这个节目点赞，在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注所有制作这个节目的人，但探索塑造我们世界设计的 99% invisible 活动的最佳方式，还是在 99pi.org 上点击阅读成百上千的故事。RADIO TAPI-O-R-X。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。